Oh as a wise man once said I've been
really trying baby to hold back this
feeling for so long and if you feel like
I feel baby
you may be wondering to yourself why oh
why am i talking about love well if you
remember last year about this time I
made a video called who's markiplier is
girlfriend but in that video I set out
to do something that I didn't accomplish
in that video my original intention
going into it was to find my youtuber
boyfriend and that didn't happen
so I'm gonna go back on the internet and
I'm gonna go on the only quiz site that
I know is capable of answering these
hard-hitting questions that live deep
within my own soul I'm gonna figure out
who my true true YouTube boyfriend is
and how will I know if they're good or
not if I don't get matched up with them
and the quiz that's the only way to know
if person is good or not worth your time
ah hey
all right cue them up knock him down
whoo you but your buttercream gang your
butt what wait what the [ __ ] is a
buttercream gang look I'm not making fun
of the name except that I'm absolutely
making fun of the name but what the [ __ ]
is a buttercream gang that sounds
horrible that's not like a gang that you
meet on a dark alley and all they do is
shove butter and cream in random places
that is a [ __ ] horror story
I've never heard of that and frankly I
don't want to you gotta find a way I
gotta find out with you I gotta find out
my buttercream gang boyfriend find out
who your buttercream gang boyfriend is
Joe sugg I know Joe sugg Ali wait no
Caspar Lee I've heard name Joshua Peters
Conor Maynard Jack Maynard Mike I don't
know any I'm so out of the loop I never
know anything ah god I don't know I live
in a bubble I live in a little bubble
which live in a fan nothing to my name I
just want
love let me see what the buttercream
gang is gonna do to me frankly I don't
even know what do you spend most of your
time doing Oh God
sports no traveling no partying do uh no
spending time with friends no if I had
friends I still wouldn't do that reading
something creative creative yeah we go
with watching YouTube obviously what's
happened music do you listen to Conor
Maynard covers I want a Google who Conor
Maynard is put I don't want to spoil the
results honor Maynard who is you who are
you I don't think screaming at your
picture is gonna do anything for that
but who are you mermaid six-pack why is
Conor Maynard 6-pack holding up some
underwear why okay alright so what I'm
discerning from this picture is at some
point in his musical act his dick starts
singing which is why he's holding his
microphone down by his crotch and if
that's true I'm very impressed
I want to listen to some Conor Maynard
covers after that okay oh no ed Sheeran
vibes no I gotta stay true oh I haven't
heard a single cover but I know they're
magical I gotta do it and I'm sorry
alright whatever
who's your favorite youtuber besides the
buttercream the buttercream so funny
fouseytube he's pretty cool I don't
watch anything but I don't want anything
I don't want anything besides a
buttercream dings oh well I heard
tutorials my favorite Shane Dawson I
live for his conspiracies James White if
he counts who's James way anyone that's
like a team tip I'm not on this list so
this is obviously [ __ ] i watch
nothing but the buttercream gang I live
for that sweet creamy butter and what I
can't wait I can't wait for that sweet
tender delicious buttercream what does a
Friday night look for you working sad
yeah yeah it's kind of true yes very
true just hanging out with friends
doesn't matter what we're doing number
one no friends number two I don't hang
out going out to dinner with family
number three I don't have family or
packing for a trip to London duh number
four
time I went to London I got the crazy
flu like I don't know if it's just all
of London is bathed in flu but I got
some and I brought it back and I was
sick for like two weeks that's why last
Christmas was all sick loaded probably
at Duke club but catching up on my
favourite ship working
sadly I'd like to think that's not a
comma there it's literally like I'm a
hunched over at my computer on a Friday
night
sadly working weeping into my dear I
mean if you think I'm making a
markiplier video I got to really get the
tears going for everything that I'm
doing so I'm not it's just seems pretty
accurate what's your favorite show right
now Glee will never die isn't Cleo ver
Teen Wolf never seen it Ellen O'Brien is
one piece of ass that doesn't sound like
a compliment
alright Dylan O'Brien are you a piece of
ass yes I don't know yes Oh maze run oh
oh the run home of mazes that guy I
can't choose because I've never watched
any of these you're on a date where do
you go nowhere does the buttercream gang
want to take me hopefully Cracker Barrel
because if there's one thing I know
about Cracker Barrel chicken and
dumplings is there it's got a lot of
butter and there's probably some cream
in there of what type I don't know but
it definitely is a possibility the beach
splashing around the water is fun no the
beach suggests the ocean and the ocean
is death no just walking around town may
be a bit of to be a bit of dancing the
only thing I pictured there was it like
we were walking around town and it was
just like hey do you like Geoff can't go
wrong with some Italian food in a movie
you can go wrong for example
[Music]
I got it you're trying to ladyandtramp
some spaghetti together but you
accidentally get it wrapped around your
own necks but you're so intensely
focused on the sucking of noodle to each
other that you accidentally sent you too
tight cut off each other's heads
death by noodle that's how Italian can
go wrong pizza and Netflix cuddling is
better than anything he can pick I'm too
indecisive a long car ride conversations
are always best kill me I'm gonna go
with death by Italian food I'm gonna
pick that one let's see who's your style
icon who is that someone a lot more
old-fashioned like Marilyn Monroe does
Harry Styles count Veronica Lodge always
I don't know who that is
ariana grande she always has accused
hair looks okay I wear what I want I
don't really look up to anyone for
fashion advice and that's not a
statement I'm a that's not like I'm
going line in the sand I'm so good
because I don't do that thing I'm just
like I can't I look at what I'm wearing
just I grabbed this out of my closet not
because I was like oh this will be fun
on camera cuz this is the first thing my
hand touched that I was like I can't
make another choice whoops oh well
describe yourself the best you can
genuine down-to-earth and loving
adventure is quiet and sweet no
adrenaline junkie honest and humorous
walk that fearless loud and stylish two
of the three two of the three of those
bubbly open-minded and creative these
are none of me where is the brash
annoying and stupid all right I'll go
fearless loud and stylish cuz frankly
look what's your favorite subject math
or science I could never choose they're
all so good I'm not in school anymore
history I love learning about the past
like when I was in school oh so long ago
I hate art always know
I'm gonna go with music cuz I was a band
NERD III played trumpet for years all
through school what's your go-to hair do
you wanna know markiplier secret style
tips for hair care I wake up
dip into my cream butter I dip into my
my vat of butter cream I scoop that and
kind of mush it until it squeezes out
between my hands and then I kind of like
just I don't really like style it like
run it through my hair I just kind of
like splat it on top and then as I go
through the day that starts to melt
naturally
and create these flowing curls of pure
grease and frankly and frankly you can't
pay for looks this good so that's yeah
that's that's what I do I'm gonna go
with natural because this is no planning
nothing I do is ever planned last one
pick your fade puppy hmm moist moist
Marcus but who's Marcus Butler who are
you who are you who are you I don't know
Marcus Butler is but I got so off-topic
that I have no idea I'm gonna pick moist
cuz I hate myself Holly who are you
congratulation you have gotten the
family oriented Ollie white hopefully
he'll love you just as much as he loves
James who's James who's oli white I want
to love you only white you hey how's it
going my name is markiplier
oh it's markiplier oh [ __ ] dude kick get
the buttercream gang it's means business
here
oh [ __ ] a book goodbye belongings see
from a tech cupboard I don't even have a
TV anymore my photos as a kid just you
know great memories and like this one of
games cupboards that's no fun in there
anymore and there's no game how I'm
gonna turn on the lights like Alexa turn
on the lights
I'm in play but Oh wagon right outside
the skull uh Oh give me all the what
it's comfy he's got a fan he's got a van
he's got a van I've got a fan I don't
know who else is in the buttercream gang
and I don't know else the buttercream
gang is about there's so many like teams
that are assembling now on YouTube and I
had no idea when that kind of started I
have no idea it's interesting it's a
fascinating thing I'm not knocking it
anyway
I just think the buttercream gang is a
funny name and I would like to know the
history of why it's called that but
anyway alley white is my youtuber
boyfriend I think I've found true love
or the most close substitution which is
a long-distance relationship where Olly
white doesn't actually know who I am
gonna kind of talk about it on the
Internet just like all my other anyway
thank you everybody so much for watching
if you want to see more stuff like this
let me know down in the comments below
if you know more about all these teams
and who the buttercream gang is fill me
in and the comments below as well and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
[Music]